I say that even to my own kids.
I tell them, you know,
do whatever interests you, you know,
whether it's martial arts,
music or whatever,
but please focus on STEM
because I think this is the future.
Sleem Hasan,
thank you so much for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Very well, thank you.
Thank you for having me.
Thank you for inviting me
to your beautiful home.
We're here in Dubai.
Sleem, start by telling me
about this painting behind us.
Because I think that it has a lot to do
with what's happening
in this room right now in our dialogue.
Well, let's pick up
from the last word you've just uttered.
Because that actually
the name of the painting.
The painting is called, The Dialogue.
And it was commissioned by a gentleman
who used to live in Dubai 15 years ago
by an artist who I had the good fortune
of meeting 20 years ago in London
way before I moved to Dubai.
And the commissioner asked,
Ralph Heimans, who is the artist,
to paint something
that focuses on the region
but focuses on interfaith.
And this is what Ralph produced,
what is behind us.
So, why is it hanging on my wall
if it was commissioned by somebody else?
So, after six months
or thereabouts in 2005,
when Ralph completed the painting
and he came to visit Dubai
for the first time,
we went to hand over the painting to
the clients who commissioned Ralph,
only to find out
when we unveiled the painting
that he disapproved of the image.
Having approved,
paid everything prior to.
So, he did a total bull of us.
And of course, Ralph was,
you know, crestfallen.
I certainly was gobsmacked
because in my world,
when you shake hands with somebody
and do a deal
and you don't renege on it.
But this was a very influential person
in Dubai at the time.
We gave him,
I was one year old in Dubai.
We gave him his money back
and we walked out
with our tails between our legs.
And then at that moment,
I turned around to Ralph Heimans,
who is the,
you know, the person who
painted this painting
called, The Dialogue, and said,
"Ralph, you know what?
I am not legally or contractually
I said to myself, obliged
but you know what?
I just felt bad."
I said, "I'll buy it
so you won't have wasted your time."
Ralph never forgot that gesture.
Today, by the grace of God,
I am one of the three people
in Ralph's world
who can actually represent him globally
on his website, ralphheimans.com
to handle his commission inquiries.
He later went on
to get his first royal commission in '06.
And then fast forward to 2012,
his first serious royal commission.
He was the only artist commissioned
by Buckingham Palace
to paint the queen
for the diamond jubilee.
That painting for any of those
who live in London,
who visit London,
I invite them to go to Westminster Abbey
because that's the final resting place
of her majesty, the queen's painting.
She's the totum factotum royal
in the planet, as you know.
And, that painting hangs
at Westminster Abbey today.
Fast forward 2018, '19.
I was here in Dubai.
And I was in Karachi
and then I came back
in the new year in '19.
And all the papers were talking about
the big event that's going to take place
for the first time in this country.
So, what was the big event?
The big event was that
Pope Francis is going to visit the UAE
for the first time.
So, we are all very excited.
You know,
the Holy See from the Vatican
is coming to Abu Dhabi.
He conducted a mass.
He came for three days
during something called
Interfaith Harmony Week,
February 3rd to 5th.
He was only here for 48 hours.
The whole world covered that event.
CNN, Reuters, Bloomberg,
all the usual suspects.
And he conducted a mass for nearly
100,000 Catholic Christians.
This was amazing.
And the interesting,
what is even more amazing
was that every paper
talked about two words
that the pope was focusing on.
Now watch my hands.
What were the two words?
Interfaith
Dialogue.
And I've got tons of newspaper articles
if you want that you can read.
When I saw these two words, I went crazy.
I said, 15 years ago,
14 years ago back then,
painting was done in Dubai by this artist
called, The Dialogue,
subject matter was interfaith.
Now, look how those words
have now moved coming out of the mouth
of the Holy See.
Right.
People came,
they want to know about this,
that about the painting.
I didn't do anything.
I just carried on.
I love that.
Fast forward this year,
you know, minding my own business,
suddenly August the 13th,
we are all reading these two words,
Abraham Accords.
When I read carefully,
I had no words.
And actually, for the first time,
I turn around
and I said, "You know what?
I'm prepared to even give this painting."
But to whom?
And for what reason?
Well, the message of this painting
is not a message that I manufactured.
It was a message that I stood by
15 years ago at a time
when there was no Abraham Accords.
Right.
Correct?
Yes.
Okay, did I plan the Abraham Accord?
No.
I'm living here.
Minding my own business
like any resident in this place,
doing my best.
And when I see the Abraham Accord,
I then reached out
to one of the ministers here
who had actually invited Ralph
in an official capacity in December 2019
for some work
and said, "You know what?
I believe this painting
deserves a gift from
a leader here to Netanyahu, for example."
They said at the time,
look, the deal has not been signed.
It's just an announcement.
Maybe it's a bit premature.
I said I'm a nobody.
It's okay.
I respect it.
Quietly, I kept my head down.
No problem.
Early September,
His Highness Abdullah bin Zayed
went to the White House
in front of the whole world,
signed Abraham Accord.
Again, before he was going,
I reached out to another minister.
I said,
I think he should give it to Trump now.
Again, there was no response.
And then I decided, you know what?
I'll rescind in my offer.
I tried.
I cannot force something
whose time has not come
and I cannot manufacture something
that does not exist.
But I know there was a message
that I stood by 15 years ago
and with God's grace,
when did the whole world
will hear about it.
Today,
if somebody came to me and says,
"Sleem, you want to sell the painting?"
"Go to Sotheby's,
go to Christie's, go to this."
I said, 'No,
we don't need Sotheby's or Christie's."
I will ask you one question.
If you can answer it,
I'll put a price on the painting.
So, what is the question?
If you can put a price
on peace between Israel
and its Arab neighbors,
i will put a price on this painting.
If you can.
I'm welcome
I'm listening.
If you can do it, welcome.
So, that's a lot of the story behind it.
In fact, this whole journey,
what I'm sharing with you now
was actually aired for the first time
about six weeks ago
through a podcast
that took place out of New York.
Alex Romanovich runs
a platform called GlobalEdgeTalk.
So, a lot of this and the material
has already been shared.
But it's in the light of,
you know, the aftermath
of the Abraham Accord,
and now, you know,
the normalization of relationships
between both sovereign states,
you know,
the story is now being told
for the first time.
Not even when Ralph,
with all due respect,
got the the commission
from Buckingham Palace.
I did not say anything.
You know, it is beautiful for Ralph.
You know, he's a,
today is referred
to as a modern day Caravaggio.
Anybody who doesn't know him,
please go and check him out.
If you want Caravaggio today,
and not Caravaggio prices, go to Ralph.
You know, I mean, you know,
but that's not the point.
The point is this has been
a long journey for me.
It's a very important journey in my life.
And it's got nothing even to do
with my main business
that I came to do in Dubai,
you know, 16 years ago.
It was the start of this business
in looking for technology entrepreneurs.
But today,
if somebody asks me, "Sleem,
what are your three passions in life?"
Okay, they're very simple now.
It's technology, art,
as you can see around the house.
We, both my wife and I are keen on that.
And interfaith dialogue.
Right.
Interfaith dialogue to me,
is very, very important.
I explain my background to you earlier.
There were Six Flags I showed you.
Right.
Right?
You know, the Fiji Islands, Pakistan,
Nigeria, UK, Japan
and now the United Arab Emirates.
You know, I can move between
these geographies quite seamlessly.
I lived in Africa.
I grew up in Africa.
I hail from Pakistan.
I worked 37 years with the Japanese.
It's a different culture.
I'm now living in the UAE for 16 years.
So it's a melange, you know,
a mixture of different people,
different types.
And that's why I look at life today.
You know, your five fingers on your hand,
they all belong to you,
they're all different sizes,
they coexist.
You've got to put all those five
fingers and they wanted to be equal,
they'd be equal.
They're not, but they coexist.
So, learn from your hand.
Lessons of life.
Sleem, you have a fascinating upbringing
all the way from Nigeria, all the way
to go into the business in Japan.
Now, in the UAE,
with three more flags in between.
Your background is in mathematics.
So, you study mathematics.
Yes, I did.
In Oxford and Cambridge.
And you transitioned from academia
to becoming a problem solver.
Tell me a little bit about your mindset,
like you did earlier,
about what it means
to be a problem solver,
whether it's in mathematics
or in life or in interfaith dialogue?
Well, look, in life, a mathematician
is trained to solve problems
at the basic,
at the essence, at the core.
So, any mathematician
worth his or her salt
will learn, keep trying
and have the ability to solve problems.
Those problems, obviously,
are mathematical in nature.
However, when you go out
into the big world,
there are other types of problems
that come about.
But the problem
and a problem solving
capacity or ability,
I see parallels between them.
It's the way your mind
is hardwired, the DNA.
I say that even to my own kids.
I tell them, you know,
do whatever interests you, you know,
whether it's martial arts,
music or whatever.
But please focus on STEM,
because I think this is the future,
you know.
And when I was 17,
I told my late parents at the time,
"You know, Dad, Mom,
I want to study Math in a University."
And I remember
my mother's words at the time.
She said, "No.
You're going to become a teacher.
What are you going to do?
Become an engineer and get a profession."
Of course, a different generation,
a different mindset.
I respect that.
However,
my dad said one beautiful thing.
He said, "Let him follow his heart."
Today, I am so grateful
that he allowed me to follow my heart
when I was 17.
And today it's that mathematics
that is really, really the core,
the essence
of how I look at everything in life.
I analyze,
I'm constantly running simulations
of things, you know.
When I meet entrepreneurs today,
I'm analyzing them literally
from the minute they open their mouth
and interact with me.
You know, and it's going on.
It's like a, you know,
the CPU of a computer,
it's just running at the back, you know,
crunching, and this is what I do.
So, I'm analyzing.
You know, they show me
a five year projections in numbers
and this and that.
You know, you can
analyze it very quickly.
And it's not conceptually difficult.
Right.
What we do now, what I'm doing right now
in the VC world,
it's not conceptually difficult.
It's more commercial.
It's more speed, access, people,
networks, you know.
But is it conceptually difficult?
No.
The part three
of the Math Tripos I did at Cambridge,
that was conceptually difficult.
This is not.
When we were sitting back in your office,
you were mentioning to me
we didn't even talk about the numbers
and the five year projections,
you we're talking about
sniffing the right entrepreneur.
Smelling the right opportunity
to partner with the right person,
not just their ideas
and not just the capital,
but the entrepreneur.
Yes.
Tell me about that as your role
as a one man VC CEO,
because that is what you are.
We talked a little bit
about your mindset before.
And one of the most remarkable things
I think about your journey
that I'm so inspired by
is your outlook
on the globality of things
and how tech integrates
all parts of the world,
not just Silicon Valley and Tel Aviv.
And you are one of the people
on the forefront of that.
Tell me a little bit about your mindset.
Well, thank you for asking that question.
And I really appreciate it.
And again, I like to break things down,
you know, in bite sizes
so people can understand it very easily.
And my answer to that is very simple.
When you go to a bar,
you meet people, you meet friends,
some you connect with,
some you don't. Correct?
What is that first exchange,
that chemistry that is taking place
that connects with one person
as opposed to somebody else
before they even open their mouth?
There's a human attraction,
there's a human proclivity,
there's a human affinity,
whatever you want to call it.
And then,
the guy opens the mouth, talks,
exchange, ideas are being exchanged.
Some are receptive to, some are not.
So, let's not take that basic thing out
from the example I cited
into the entrepreneur world.
Say you meet an entrepreneur
for the first time.
Some people you will connect with,
some people you will not.
The ones you don't connect with
doesn't mean they don't have a good idea.
The chances are as a VC this size,
you know, and you have 24 hours in a day,
it becomes part
of your filtering mechanism.
The ones you connect with
and then you like the idea,
that's a good starting off point.
So, I say,
I only am agnostic to geography
as I am to industry vertical.
I only care about the underlying
compelling value proposition of the idea.
Open your mouth
and appeal to my intellect.
Once you appeal to it,
I will get engaged.
Once I get engaged,
doesn't mean I'm right.
I have a three companies
that's right in my portfolio.
I've got three exits.
I've got one company that's got
the backing and funding with tier-one
Silicon Valley couple VCs sitting here
in that little office you came into
in Dubai?.
So, this is my journey.
This is what I do.
I connect with people,
I connect with cultures,
I connect with all religions,
I connect with society
and I'm not saying it.
I've done it.
I've connected with all kinds of people.
Even way before the Abraham Accord
that is now official,
i had many Jewish friends.
Some from Israel, some, you know,
Persian Jews or, you know,
Jews from wherever.
You know, I have a lot of friends.
But it was never something that
I grew up seeing,
oh, that guy's a Buddhist,
that guy's an Indian,
that guy's a Jew.
No, it's not the way I was brought up.
I was brought up by my parents.
That's my late father picture
I'm pointing to over there
and my late mother is over there.
They are beautiful.
Yeah.
I was brought up to respect people.
You know, my dad used to always tell me,
"Son, you take any two people in the world
and ask them
how many hours in your day."
Answer, 24.
How many in yours? 24.
On what basis
is this time more valuable than yours?
It's a mathematical constant.
First differential is zero.
How can your time
be more valuable than his.
And you take any five people in a room,
all different nationalities. One Spanish,
one Indian, one Israeli, one Jewish,
one Japan, whatever.
And you make a small cut in their skin.
If the color that comes out
from any one of those
people is different, come back to me.
This is how I was brought up.
This is the fundamental tenets
I use to lead my life.
I'm not impressed about money.
I'm not impressed about,
people who sit on billions
of dollars of funds.
First, it's not theirs.
And if it was theirs, okay, great.
With hard work,
I have no objections to that.
But to tell me you manage a fund
of somebody else's money
and it does not impress you
because that but a great idea,
I bow my head to that.
Again,
another quote from my late father.
He said, "Son,
you bow your head to two things in life.
First and foremost, your creator.
Second, in that order,
superior intellect."
I've taken his words
and I made a business out of it.
Today, the people I bow my head to
are the entrepreneurs.
They're the smart ones, not me.
So, respect the entrepreneur.
And today, with interest rates
being next to zero or negative,
even the market doesn't
value money anymore.
So, who am I to stand in the way of that?
What does the fund mean?
I don't know.
You're talking about bowing your head
to the entrepreneurs
and not necessarily the capital
or whatever the status is.
But you are an entrepreneur yourself.
You sold your company.
Yes.
And then you put your own capital
with no outside investment to Privity also,
the VC fund that you own yourself.
It's your own money in it.
Why go that route?
Why go the route
where you are investing in yourself?
Because it seems to be
a big part of who you are, right?
Well, perhaps it is.
You know, I mean,
in life, I tried working
in a corporate world.
I did well in a corporate world.
But there was too much fire in the belly.
And, you know, I was
running when everybody was walking.
And I was walking
when everybody was sitting,
you know, so, it's who I am.
And I am not here
to impose my views on anybody.
I see people want to build
multi-billion dollar empires.
Great, do it.
But I have my own journeys in life
and I also go to my own beliefs.
And part of that quote of my own beliefs
is the,
I was also influenced by a book
I read by Todd Henry, Die Empty.
I believe that's where
we all will end up.
You know the book?
I don't.
This is important, I think,
for your fellow students
and whoever you are sharing this with.
Somebody was asked one day,
where do you find the most
expensive real estate in the world?
This is the theme of the book,
which is really influenced me.
And it said, somebody said, you know,
Tokyo, the Imperial Gardens,
somebody said Rockefeller Center.
Somebody said, you know,
Buckingham Palace, wherever.
He said, "No, you are all wrong.
That is not the
most expensive real estate
in the world."
And you've got
all these big funds buying real estate.
You know, now guess
what covid has done to it.
We don't know.
It's not me.
I didn't do covid, you know,
something happened.
But he said in this book, he said,
"The graveyard
is the most expensive real estate
in the world."
And the guy asked him,
"Why is the graveyard
the most expensive real estate
in the world?"
He said,
"You know, the number of people
with amazing ideas
who did not share it with the world,
who end up six feet under?
What a waste to humanity."
When I started absorbing that,
I said, "What's the point
of chasing money?"
Yes, you need something to live,
eat, a roof over your head.
There's enough in this world
for everyone's need,
but certainly not enough in this
world for everyone's greed.
So, it was a rewiring of the brain.
So, I'm happy to do it on my journey.
If somebody wants to join, welcome.
I have a very simple philosophy in life.
Never say no to the first cup of coffee.
I learned that when
through Ralph actually, the artist
20 years ago.
Because was my mind
was focused in Japan trading
and anything that was out of that world
I didn't want to, no,
keep an open mind, meet people,
try different experiences,
different cultures, eat different food.
You know, spend time travelling
when once covid allows,
you know, things normalize a bit.
And this gives you a much better rounded,
balanced view of life.
But this is the way I've been brought up.
I loved it.
Sleem, this was inspiring.
Thank you for sharing with me
your journey, your passion,
both for technology, for ideas,
but also for interfaith and dialogue.
I really didn't expect this coming in.
And I think it's a remarkable,
inspiring for me
as I'm ending here on my trip
in Dubai this past week
to have this as the final conversation.
It leaves me with inspiration,
hope and mainly excitement
to come back.
Welcome, any time.
And work on really
impactful things together.
So thank you very, very much.
Shalom.
The very last thing that I have to ask,
which is the most important question,
three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
I have a feeling
I know some of them already
and I have a feeling
you mentioned them already,
but three words that anybody
who knows Sleem Hasan
would say about you.
Well, I think first and foremost,
it would be passionate.
Yeah.
You know, persistent and perseverance.
Those are the three piece
that guide me in my life.
I never give up to anything.
If I fundamentally have
a core belief in something,
nobody can change my mind
other than an act of God who was my
the ultimate, my creator and who's
leased my life to me.
Our lives have been leased to us.
We don't even own that.
So, we don't own that.
How can we put claims
and other things when our own,
the most precious things
we don't even own.
You know,
it's a fundamental philosophical way
of looking at life.
And because of that,
then you suddenly realize,
you're just a,
you know, a tiny little speck,
you know.
And it puts things into perspective,
And to me,
i never like to talk about it,
but, you know,
there's a wonderful poem that
when I was 15,
I learned by the guy
who wrote Pilgrim's Progress
called John Bunyan.
It's called Contentment.
Again, this poem influenced
me in my life when I was 15.
And I recommend anyone to Google
and just check it out
if they're not already read it.
And I'll just read the first
stanza for you, you know.
He that is down needs fear no fall,
He that is low, no pride;
He that is humble, ever shall
Have God to be his guide.
That first stanza, you know,
has influenced me in my life.
Nothing wrong with being down and low,
you will never fall.
You will never fall in life.
You can only fall when you rise
and you will fall when you rise because
you know certain things overtake
those basic tenets
that you lose track of
as you are rising.
If you don't lose it,
you will continue to rise.
I love it.
Sleem, thank you very much.
You're welcome.
This is wonderful.